these are questions that I got here from
the North Carolina State University
paper and so I'm just going to answer
them in video format so that I guess
everyone can enjoy them if they if they
find them enjoyable so question number
one where did you get the idea of making
such a website what was the inspiration
or reason so and I forgive me if any of
you were tired of hearing the story but
it really did start with my cousins not
in particular in 2004 I started tutoring
her and really everything that is the
Khan Academy now or at least a lot of
its initial stages were out of me as a
tutor needing tools to help my cousin so
the first software and it was actually
written before the first video I started
working on in 2005 was a way to give my
cousin's not able being one of them and
then our brothers practice and also for
me to be able to keep track of of what
they were doing and for them and for me
to be able to not use the time that we
had on the phone kind of doing all of
the practice problems as they could do
it on their own then I started making
the videos so that they could pause and
repeat and wanted a lot of the stuff at
their own pace at their own time and
then we could use we could use our our
in-person time it was still remote
tutoring but our in-person time to do
the exact problems that they were having
so it's been a very organic process all
the way you get to last year where we
got our major funding and once again it
was you know what are the needs of the
students that we're hearing from on
YouTube that are messaging us even this
whole notion of what's happening in los
altos and the pilots and the other
pilots were now starting in this this
year we we kind of thought that
eventually we could use it in schools
but it was one of these opportunities
that just happened through through
happenstance or someone reached out to
us and said hey what would you do if you
could do anything you want with the
fifth grade classroom and we told them
and that's what we've been doing so so I
guess you know there's the inspiration
or the reason i guess i can give credit
to my cousins and maybe a little bit to
my own kind of a you know when i was
when i was going through schooling
myself i did sometimes feel frustrated
that we couldn't use class time in a
more interactive way or or that we
couldn't learn at our own pace but you
know it really has been a very organic
gradual process of layering on things
that seemed to make sense and building
them and then seeing if they work and we
actually think we're still in the very
early stages of that process and that we
have a long way to go and a lot more
things to experiment and test question
number two where do you get all the
videos from so the simple answer to this
first part of the question is we get
them all from me right now i am the only
faculty i'm the only person on the site
right now we love 2500 i think we're
even pushing 2600 videos right now and
then the second part of the questions
are the coach is allowed to upload their
own personal videos so right now the
coaches are not allowed to upload their
own personal because obviously they can
tell students independently of Khan
Academy that they could watch those
videos but this is something that we are
very seriously looking at and not just
coaches but we are we're very seriously
looking at a way for people to create
their own Khan Academy experience on top
of our platform that they could expose
either to their students or to the world
generally and we hope that they would
expose them to the world's generally
right now it's just an engineering
bottleneck we don't have the bandwidth
to do it although we think it could be a
really powerful thing closer to that in
terms of where do we get all the videos
this is something that you expect to
hear a lot more from us soon some people
might have noticed that I have started
to do some videos experimenting with
this interview form factor where I'm
getting outside experts but I'm there as
well I'm there as well talking to them
about about some of these concepts and
you know and then educating me but
you'll also see we're bringing on some
full-time faculty members and the
humanities soon who I think have made
some tremendous videos and so their
libraries are going to be integrated
suit and I think people are going to
really enjoy it so the short answer all
the videos right now for me in the next
few months you're going to see some
other very talented teachers come into
the mix that we've really found to be
rock stars and then
you four go out maybe another year year
and a half I think you're going to have
ways for coaches to create or just
people generally to create use Khan
Academy's more generalized learning
platform but and it's an open question
on how much that becomes a mainstream
experience or do we use kind of crowd
sourcing to to curate the content to say
what's good and what's not is still open
question we haven't we haven't really
figured that one out what is your target
audience so are it's a kind of a simple
answer no you know you don't find that
I'm not answering the question but it's
really everybody it's it's really anyone
who you know let's say put an
independent of the the traditional
schooling system or the traditional
hurdles people have to jump through so
anyone who wants to learn anyone who's
curious about the world that's our
target audience and we see it we get
letters from people who are in the 30s
40s 50s 70s who are just learning for
fun so that is our target audience but
on top of that we obviously care about
the stakeholders in other people's
learning so teachers and parents and so
we are also trying to make sure that
they find us to be a very useful tool in
their arsenal that can hopefully a
transformational tool in their arsenal
to make their classes all that more rich
and interactive number four in many
cases the students open some social
networking or other websites or play
games as soon as they sit in front of a
computer I think that is true so do you
think teaching online lectures education
can substitute the in-class way of
teaching well it depends what the
in-class way of teaching is and it
depends on what students motivations are
I mean it's true students like they like
to go to Facebook or social or websites
or whatever else and the reality is is
that's getting in the way of not just
you know online learning that's getting
in the way of learning period i'm sure
that's getting in the way of the
traditional homework and studying that
they have to do right now and to some
degree the fact that the studying is
only a click away makes it a little bit
easier than the fact that the studying
is go to your knapsack and take out a
textbook and turn to page 543 and then
read that dense text and then open up
your now notebook and do every other odd
problem or whatever it is whatever your
homework assignment might be I actually
think it lowers the threshold to
starting the
interaction with the learning I think it
also lowers it because I would hope that
our content is viewed as approachable
content and content that focuses on the
the beauty of the learning as opposed to
the kind of the mechanical nature of the
learning so and I think when most people
are exposed to that they find it much
more satisfying and you know on a broad
level maybe this is being a little bit
too helpful I think I think the cut when
content becomes interesting everyone
does feel better when they're learning
than when they spend you know five hours
stalking people on a social networking
site and so I think once people
experience it they're like you know what
I actually enjoy it when I spend more
time learning than what i'm going to do
other things but with that said it's an
open question and we don't we don't
claim to sit solve it and like I've
answered in a previous interview if if
people are going to skip out on if if
people are when they go home if they're
not going to do their assignments or if
they're not going to do their learning I
would rather they skip out on on
lectures then skip out on doing problems
and so that's where I think this whole
notion of flipping a classroom or
whatever is important is that if
someone's not going to do any work at
home whether it's watching videos or
doing traditional homework it's when you
go to the classroom I still think it's
more important that students do problems
there with their peers and their teacher
there then getting this this lecture
that they may or may not be able to be
prepared for or be able to pay attention
to or that they might not find engaging
and they never get to do the practice
but the ideal obviously is that they
they use the human time in the classroom
for interaction and then they go home
and there they do exercises and and
videos at their own base so it's not
just watching lectures at home it's
exercises and videos whatever is
whatever is appropriate at that stage of
learning process question number five
what according to you is the future of
online education well having lectures on
I don't think I answered the second part
of that first question so do you think
online lectures education can substitute
the in-class way of teaching I think I
think online lectures education can
substitute the in-class way of lecturing
especially the relatively
non-interactive lectures
I've been a part of and College of the
rest where it's really a professor
lecturing and everyone taking notes and
there's very little interaction I don't
think it's as a substitute for in-class
discussion or in class simulations or in
class problem solving or in class
interaction and to take it a step
further I actually think it's a catalyst
I think online lectures education
selfish problems they're not something
that's a substitute for in-class
interaction there a catalyst for
in-class interaction because when you
can get everything done at your own pace
at your own time then that makes the
conversation you have in class the
project's the experiments explorations
you have in class that much more
productive and it frees up time for them
to actually think it's a catalyst for it
and not a not a substitute number five
what according to you is the future of
online education well having lectures
online have impact on the way students
are taught in the class well answer the
second part first and that's kind of
what I just touched on yes I think you
know right now universities are already
telling this to determine high schools
hey go do the reading read page 40
through 70 tonight and then come back to
lecture the next day and you'll get a
better experience some students do it
some students don't we think the videos
are much more approachable thing to have
to do the night before and even if the
student doesn't do it the night before
the value is you you always have it
there so even if you don't do the night
before and you you know traditional
model right now you go to class and
you're lost because you didn't do the
reading at least now you have the
equivalent of a lecture that's and I
think better because it's granular and
all the rest that you can review when
you need to do it pause and repeat
review things from previous years but
you know it's going to have a way it has
a huge impact I think on the way
students are talking clock because they
will no longer be electric because that
is what's happening outside so I think
our biggest role i think you know i
can't emphasize this enough is we are
all about taking lecture out of the
class we're not saying that lecture is
the best way to learn we're just saying
let's take it out of the class we're
saying that interaction with teachers
and your peers are the best way to learn
and we hope to be a catalyst we hope to
be a catalyst for that in terms of what
is the future of online education open
question we don't even know what the
future of the khan academy
is it something that we're constantly
experimenting with being open-minded
about what works and what doesn't and
then then adapting and and so you know
it's not something that I'm a hundred
percent sure I I hope there's a future
five or ten years where anyone can go
online and get a deep learning or
understanding of anything and then on
top of that I hope there's a way that
they can prove what they know so that
they could credential they can say look
I don't need to take algebra anymore
because I've proven that I really
understand this and it could be with
traditional exams or it could be and
this is what's interesting about online
maybe it's something with crowd based
oral exams where if you want to become a
level five algebraic and your level for
right now there's already level there's
you know five out of five level five
people have to say that you're ready for
level five or ready to be deep level
five and reduced skype or meet up or who
knows what it might be to be evaluated
so there's even ways with online
education to bring the best of physical
education into a scalable way right now
the gold standard of examination is the
oral examination but it only happens for
during PhD qualifiers because it's not
there aren't the resources to do it for
people kind of the undergraduate or
regular k through 12 level but I think
with crowdsourcing we could start to
explore some some really interesting
ways but we don't know the answers there
number six with respect to your article
in The Wall Street Journal regarding the
Khan Academy could you please elaborate
the concept of taking lectures at home
and doing homework in class so this is
something I really want to emphasize
because this really caught on after I
gave a TED talk about flipping the
classroom and the idea there was I
mentioned is that hey you know I've made
these videos and I started getting
letters from teachers who said hey you
made the videos so the teachers then
start to assign the videos as homework
and then using class time for actual
homework for actually doing problem
solving which i think is super important
but that was halfway through the TED
talk and and what we're trying to do
with Khan Academy is really go a step
further than that and say whether you're
in at home or in the classroom or on the
train learn at your own pace whether
it's watching videos or doing exercises
whatever is appropriate for you learn at
your own pace and then your teacher will
have data on where you what you've been
working on and
whether you are stuck and so that when
you go with that interaction with the
teacher if you don't need any help maybe
some of it is still working continuing
to work at your own pace with videos and
exercises but the teacher will know when
you do need help so even if you're shy
they'll have that data and they can come
up to you and hopefully have a
productive intervention with you and so
what we're saying is it's not so much
about a pure flip we think it's a step
beyond that everyone works at their own
pace at their own time mastering
concepts before they move on and the
real crux of what the Khan Academy about
is about is making that that class time
as interactive as possible and
leveraging that human in the room
whether it's a teacher or your peers so
that they can do what humans are best at
which is mentor understand diagnose
understand what exactly a student's
problem is and take it to the next level
do what the videos and the exercises
could not do